pub
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ce trop tôt dans ce bagne aux nazis ou
le four crématoire est resté debout
passèrent pendant les années
d'occupation des milliers et des
milliers de français déportés quand bien
en sont parvenus à femmes et torturés
suppliciés
c'est à leur souvenir qu'a été érigé
cette flamme de pierre haute de 41
mètres que le général de gaulle a voulu
inaugurer lui même au pied de ce
mémorial on viendra désormais s'incliner
devant la tombe du déporté inconnues
autour duquel garde d'honneur immobile
et tragique s'alignent les tombes de 900
des portes et ramené de tous les camps
de la mort avec douaumont avec le mont
valérien
struth au fait devenu aujourd'hui l'un
des plus hauts lieux du sacrifice dans
les chantiers de brest à côté du porte
avions clemenceau son homologue le foch
a été mis à l'eau en présence de la
fille du grand soldat de 1918 qui
conduisit à la victoire les armées
alliées le fauche avait été construit à
saint nazaire puis conduit à brest pour
y recevoir son armement domaine place
que le clemenceau il mesure 2 157 m et
jauge trente-et-une mille tonnes
il transportera une soixantaine d'avions
mais nous atteindrons 1963 pour le voir
entrer en service
[Musique]
cet homme de 49 ans règne sur un empire
de béton sa baguette fait jaillir des
sites et 9 à un rythme inconnu avant lui
il est connu aux etats-unis comme en
urss
il s'appelle raymond camus il est devenu
la providence de milliers d'enfants que
la crise du logement vous aux russes en
dhr et otto dix depuis dix ans cet homme
en effet révolutionne l'art de bâtir les
maisons son secret à la pique nique
séculaire qui a vu des générations de
masse ont empilé un à un des moellons
puis des briques
il a tout simplement eu l'idée de
substituer celle des chaînes de montage
des usines d'automobiles
ainsi est né à montesson la plus
puissante en france des usines à maison
car c'est bien du sinn qu'il faut parler
aux fabriques ici tous les éléments d'un
logement complet voici par exemple un
ferraillage munis de certains de
chauffage qui va servir au moulage du
plancher d'une pièce
de la même façon sont fabriqués les
différents murs de cette pièce et tous
ceux du logement y compris les murs de
façade car les ainsi de lusine de monter
son sort
un logement par heure en pièces
détachées mûr prêt à recevoir compteur
réseau électrique plancher déjà équipés
de leur parquet ou de leurs carrelage il
ne reste plus aux tracteurs qui a
acheminé ces éléments vers les chantiers
chantier qui en vérité mériterait mieux
le nom de chaînes de montage
ici les opérations ont été réduites au
minimum par le procédé de raymond camus
la mise en place par les grues des
éléments de murs munis de leurs fenêtres
celle ensuite des planchers place en
daim à ces chantiers la lieue de jeu de
construction géant six jours suffisent
au montage complet d'un étage d'immeuble
par la suite les diverses tuyauterie
viendront d'elles mêmes ou presque
prendre leur place comme d'ailleurs tout
le réseau des fils électriques
les conteurs et autres équipements il en
sera de même des plus grosses
canalisations chauffage écoulement d'eau
vide ordures pour chaque élément
complémentaire toujours quelques gestes
suffiront à sa mise en place
l'application des méthodes industrielles
au bâtiment par sa possibilité de
production est limitée peut désormais
résoudre ce problème
loger tout le monde mais aussi parce
qu'elles se passent de spécialistes elle
ouvre un nouveau domaine d'emploi à la
main d'heure c'est sans doute tout cela
qui explique qu'aujourd'hui les usines à
maison de raymond camus s'édifie aussi
bien en urss qu'au canada à hambourg
qu'à constantine
[Musique]
qu'allait devenir le congo constellation
us débarquant des troupes suédoises
iliouchine soviétique débarquant des
forces ghanéenne se succédaient sur
l'aérodrome de n'djili aux portes de
léopoldville l'onu atteint son
intervention les casques bleus partout
dans la ville avait remplacé les belges
la rue avait retrouvé son calme et sa
curiosité
le problème s'était déplacé dans le
katanga la plus méridionale des
provinces congolaises
monsieur moïse tshombe leader d'un
nouveau nationalisme proclamé
l'indépendance du katanga et i7 à
elisabethville sa capitale les tout neuf
couleurs d'une nation à peine née
nouveaux problèmes qui s'ajoutaient aux
problèmes d'ensemble car des îlots
tragique subsistaient
à 300 km de léopoldville un commando
belges étaient envoyés pour délivrer 120
colombes cerné par les rebelles dans le
petit centre de bugnes à l'opération
rapidement donnée qui laissait quelques
cadavres et quelques blessés mais
permettait de rapatrier les familles en
danger
pendant ce temps à new york le conseil
de sécurité écouter le dialogue
dramatique engagé entre belgique et
congo je crois que le représentant de la
belgique répond le nombre de victimes
est longue des belges et comme pour
répondre en tant que représentant du
gouvernement congolais
nous considérons comme victime tous ceux
qui sur le territoire national opt
victimes des désactivant les incidents
et d'autres faits précis
le ton change avec le délégué belge qui
dans un silence oppressant rappelle les
heurts sanglants et les troupes être
soit intervenu strictement en raison du
devoir sacré de protéger la vie et
l'honneur de nos ressortissants
ats ville madame j a vu la porte de
l'officier via les neuf fois en présence
de sept enfants sur les freins coop
femmes que compte encore 10 43 44 ont
été violées afin d'obliger il continué
c'est vrai que nous faisions confiance
au gouvernement congolais et ce sans
doute vrai qu'il nous faisait confiance
aussi là il me faudra du temps vous
savez pour que j'oublie ce 30 juin pour
toutes les femmes que nous avions laissé
sur place avec nos enfants sur les bras
a clamé les deux souverains qui passait
votre président et notre roi
monsieur kanza voyez vous que si nous
avions préparé des complots ou des
agressions nous aurions été de tels
traîtres et de tels gens sans au nord
voilà une malheureuse choses qui nous
ont séparés
est-ce pour lui répondre lui-même que de
léopoldville s'envoler pour les
états-unis monsieur lumumba qui venait
de signer avec le financier dettwiller
un accord d'assistance de 2 milliards de
dollars
le point crucial
restait le port de matadi occupée par
les mutins en armes qui n'acceptaient
pas sans difficulté l'arrivée des
marocains du colonel driss missionné par
l'onu
le port offrait à ce moment un spectacle
lamentable
plus de 300 voitures abandonnées par les
belges aux émigrés en obstruaient les
abords des pillards de toutes sortes les
avaient vidé
dans les rues boutiques et magasins
offrait le même spectacle affligeant des
lendemains de pillage ou de catastrophes
de leur camp de raids jaf un millier de
soldats mutinés armé d'un matériel de
guerre important avait fait une sorte de
cour des miracles encombré de
trouvailles disparates fruit de quinze
journées de pillage
cette troupe dans son désordre et son
incurie allait-elle cependant résisté et
vendre matadi au prix du sang les
marocains de l'onu sûr éviter l'écueil
devant une foule curieuse mais sans
réaction ils firent d'une entrée résolu
et presque solennelle du même coup
matadi ville de 60000 habitants fut
délivré à la fois du drame et de la peur
quelques petits groupes de muta ses skis
verte avec leurs armes pour gagner la
brousse tout le reste c'est à
ayant hissé les couleurs de l'onu le
général kettani et le colonel driss ray
attrill dans 24 heures aux mutins
l'ordre et la discipline est raide jaf
comme matadi a retrouvé son visage est
ce maintenant la fin du drame
[Musique]